it's Tuesday the 26th of September
welcome to the check-in it's brought to
you by Blue Jew listen I love blue chew
everybody loves a guy who's self-assured
in the bedroom and Bluetooth can help
make sure you're ready whenever the mood
strikes blue chew is an online service
that delivers Ed medicine straight to
your door nobody knows nothing with the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra but at a fraction of the
cost just sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you're you receive your
prescription within days
it's all online no doctor's office
nobody giving you a brow beating it's a
beautiful thing they each come in a
little blue package when you feel
something or you bump into somebody that
could be a stranger you're pop one and
you do what you need to do Bluetooth
comes in a discreet package so your nosy
no neighbors don't ever know what they
got unless they want the Yum Yum you
know what I'm saying
Bluetooth wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com again chew it and do it
Jack that's a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
have promo code Joey at checkout just
pay five dollars for shipping again
that's
bluetooth.com code Joey to receive your
first month visit bluetooth.com for more
details remember promo code Joey and the
check-in is also brought to you by Babel
listen I know I'm babbling right now
anyway only 22 percent of Americans
speak a language can you believe that
even me Uncle Joey I got like three
languages
[Laughter]
if you want to shake up your daily
routine why not learn a new language and
help raise that rate you ever get on a
on an Uber you don't know what nobody's
saying this is the perfect time when you
get a little boy to have Bible instead
of paying hundreds of dollars for a
private tutor or use another language
apps the little more than games Babel is
an effective way to give your Uber
driver a tremendous air beat designed by
over 150 language experts using Babel
for just 15 hours 15 hours has shown to
be equivalent to a full semester of
college language course listen I played
with Babel a little bit I like that
little Spanish course give it a try you
know Spanish is the number one language
people are talking right now you want to
jump on that bandwagon you always want
to be able to get into the baseball game
you know what I'm saying with over 10
million subscriptions so Babel is a real
language learning for real conversations
his especially limited deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
get 55 off your Babel prescriptions but
only
for our listeners at babel.com Joey
again
babel.com Joey I'm getting you 55 off
who gives you a deal like that nobody
fell Babel B
X slash Joey rules and restrictions May
apply welcome to the check-in
I love your TVs run for your lives it's
over they didn't put you on this planet
just think about if Uncle Joey could do
it I could rule the world actually you
got to be thinking
[Music]
what's the story stop boy doing all
right you can never tell I'll never stop
the Jews
you know what I'm saying
all the brothers in the struggle like
I've said for years don't sleep on the
juice
[Laughter]
also aren't supposed to eat Edibles on
Yom Kippur
in the Bible for the Gentiles
and for the Corinthians and for the
dude but the Jews do what the
they want on Yom Kippur there's
only one night you don't want to do
anything and that's the night the
ghost comes into the door
because if you eat mushrooms or edibles
you might see them oh no you
mean Elijah yeah we want him to come but
no you can't that's the one day a year
Jews don't eat we don't eat you can't
eat you're not supposed to have edibles
like I'm about to do to you
can you do that because I go up there
with a girl named Nancy with one eye and
a needle you'll be done you
understand me done what does she have
one eye I because she lost it in Vietnam
I don't know I never asked her you ever
see somebody with a missing eye you
don't ask him why'd you lose your eye
that's an interesting iPad you had
no how many how often do you see people
with one eye I don't think I've ever
seen someone what
oh I live in remember the time we saw
one of the guy in San Diego oh yeah when
the pirate and Dean who has that tape I
still have it hold on I just dropped it
let me find it or or Joe if you can go
to my Instagram
how was your weekend
my weekend
was pretty good man I I didn't do I
didn't do to be honest with I had a
show on Thursday
that I didn't do great at but thank you
to everyone who came out a couple people
from the check and came out listen we
inviting people from the check-in and
then you you told me to I didn't
bomb I didn't and you got a dub you
gotta double check that you can't
drop a bomb on these
you know what I'm saying
you got to say timer I got some people
here from the check-in I gotta start
this all over again
I don't think they'd like that yes they
win two hours I gotta start over yeah
you can't start over yes you can who
says I did it's not who says it's an art
you can do whatever the you want
you get on stage you're having a rough
time for two minutes call a timeout
listen I gotta go get my head together
I'll be right back sorry about that I
didn't know what I was thinking
I don't know if I ever told this story
you remember the time that you convinced
me that Chappelle was gonna go before me
like the first time I did the belly room
with Eric
oh
oh we it's all goddamn day well
you did because you didn't tell me you
told me you get to get to The Comedy
Store Eric Rocha who was on the church a
bunch of very funny comic we went and we
didn't even feel comfortable going if
there's a uh the comics only bar at the
store and I felt like an like I
didn't want to go like I wasn't going to
just walk in there so we asked somebody
and they got us in
and immediately you're with Agostino and
the first thing you did you didn't say
hi you threw you remember you had those
edible mints for a minute
you had edible mint
able gasoline too what are we getting at
it you threw them in my mouth and he
said hey you're not hosting anymore
Chappelle's going up he wants to do half
an hour in front of you and you
everyone in the bar was like oh
like everyone so you let me burn and
sweat I mean half an hour away
we got up to the belly room and
you're like ah he's not here and I I was
so high and so nervous I forgot Eric's
name
when I was bringing him up I had been
doing comedy with him for two years
you convinced me that Chappelle want to
do 30 in front of me you gotta that's
part bro when you realize that comedy is
all mental
you'll do a lot better you know you for
years I put this fear in my head I had a
thousand different fears from they have
white hair and they're drinking too much
you know
the Jewish half of them in Spanish
you know it's half of them I grew up
with I can't do this material in front
of them and then one day I said
them all so
let's talk about Thursday night and
why you thought you didn't do well
because that's another part of the show
that I want to talk to you about when
you have a spot during the week and it
doesn't go your way let's review it I
don't need to watch the tape
okay by the sound of your voice and your
honesty I know where you're taking this
you know we can't always kill every
night right now you're a five-year comic
you're working on percentages
you know
I I don't kill
people say I'm hot I always remember you
were very
I don't want to say hard on yourself you
I use the word realistic when I'm
talking about it because you've had
nights that I saw you that I thought you
killed and you're like
and it
I haven't been doing like I'm not
killing every night but I went on a run
there of having pretty good like sets I
was happy with bees like at least
and then on Thursday night I just
I can blame some things about the show
like where how where I went up but the
comedy club is great
I just
I didn't feel like I was in the moment
and I just felt like I was I've been
trying to do different orders
and
you know what we you ever go to a comedy
movie in the theater and if you laugh
the whole time
and then you go and you try to watch it
at home and it sucks two years later or
even whenever it just sucks the audience
plays a big part and for me and I start
off not great it tends like I can
sometimes dig myself out of it but if
like the audience isn't into it I just
feel like I'm not really
present or flowing
I've been there
I loved you know for a long time like
you I struggled you know uh once you the
first three jokes bomb there ain't no
coming back you know what I'm saying
once you once you're all in two we're
done at that level you know it just it's
just the way the ball bounces you know
you all win two even two perfect
strikes down your throat what are the
chances of you coming up with anything
else you know and maybe you didn't see
the pitch maybe you weren't focused you
know
um I was the king of bombing it got to a
point where I embraced it because I knew
this would pass
what do you mean you embraced it
listen man when you your I'm
not going to become something overnight
after one set that I'm not
you know what I'm saying like it's just
not gonna uh
so I kind of embraced it being there for
a while
and when I would have a good set I would
feel that much better
oh it feels great
and I still guys you know like I've told
you a thousand times I bombed in bars I
bombed on one-nighters in different
states
and I bombed at the place where it
really mattered
I bombed horribly at The Improv horribly
on a Monday night in front of everybody
and I bombed miserably at the store
and once you come back from that
bombing ain't that bad it's like going
to Jujitsu and getting tapped
but they also I want you to attack you
know I don't ever want you to live in
that bomb
that's the most important thing is
living in that bomb three years from now
when you're at a theater nobody's gonna
remember that bomb bomb bong you
know what's on my mind
bomb you know so don't always remember
don't matter
I'm telling you this 30 years in
those bombings the first 10 years
you know it's like uh
a football team when they first get
together and for four years they just
suck
they're all in 11 2-1
219 you know five and whatever the
mathematical equation is and then one
year they just come out and they come
out throwing heat that's comedy
but sometimes they'll lose
when San Francisco 49ers in the Heyday
they could win 18 touchdowns 18
Super Bowls but they couldn't beat
the New Orleans Saints
what does it feel like do you feel any
different to like
imagine you were headlining a theater if
you bomb one of those shows
horrible
is it worse or is it just one of the
worst things I did the last five years
was that night I bombed in New Orleans
that and that picture hangs in
my bathroom so every time I pee well I
gotta poop I look up on the wall and I
go yeah New Orleans tremendous
it's a great picture the House of Blues
gave me
but till this day I just didn't like how
I performed I remember I got better
after that like you know you learn from
every bombing at every level yeah I got
an email
from a comic and he said that uh
we spoke a lot about bombing and he said
he went to the comedy Mothership last
night that last weekend he seen the bomb
of bombs it was like somebody big you
know and he didn't meet in a jokey way
he wasn't putting the guy down he was
just asking me like how do you recover
from that you know it's a hot club it
sold out and everybody just watched you
bomb at Joe Rogan's Club you
know and I told him the comic is a
professional
you know Aaron judge won't hit a
home run for two weeks then he pulled
three of them out of his ass and you
forget about those two weeks right
that's
I don't know if you can relate to this
where I am right now like I'll have a
weekend sometimes and then we'll be like
eight weeks until the weekend if I bomb
the last show or really anytime I bomb
like I'll run to an open mic I'll run
I I like I have to get to another spot
and like it kills me if I have like a
few weeks until another real show no
that's the right attitude
you're not gonna not get on stage
because you bombed one night
if you get if you bomb on a
Tuesday night
I hope you wake up looking for an open
mic I hope you find the night I hope you
find an Irish bar
that'll uh you know I hope you
find an Irish bar that doesn't open mic
at 8 A.M or you're something
at 8 am open yeah no it
I don't know how else to compare it like
it's just
I feel like I have like on me like
literal
why but if I don't get a decent setting
after a bomb
at least something
yeah I have to
you know even early on I would go home
and depending on what level or what year
I was in you know there were some nights
that I I cried after a bombing
you know there were some nights that I
went home and wrote the set out
there were some nights I'm not gonna lie
to you I went home and blamed it on the
audience like that's what a chump comic
does
a chump comic of all the he had a
Mickey Mouse sound system well
after the first minute you
dropped the mic and yell over him
you know I'm deaf nothing sucks than
going to a show and I can't hear the
comic or something else
so you know if if you know the whole
room has that problem
drop the mic and get on a table
I don't give a what it takes
look at it that way
you know if you bomb on a Tuesday night
and you're not an 11 30 matinee of The
Expendables before
doing 10 minutes in front of
those remotes you got a problem that's
where the problem lies you're not going
to be a good comment because you're
scared of getting back on the horse
that's it you just go back there that
day and you're gonna bomb again at that
movie Peter yeah
because you had the balls to go down
there and bomb
well
I did comedy for about a year you know
and I thought I was Joey bananas you
know I didn't know what it took to be a
comic I thought you got on stage four or
five times and people like your
cigarettes and whatnot
and that was like uh
you know when I started comedy the first
three years
there were still a lot of national
contests Lee
I am very good uh Johnny Walker black
had one HBO had one in Las Vegas and you
got invited to by sending a tape
and then you did the top five Comics did
spots in front of agencies
uh you know I actually won the best
broker Joker uh competition in
Boulder in 91. congratulations there
were a lot of uh cop
contest
and I'll never forget that there was one
like on a Thursday morning at Comedy
Works in Denver
I had been on stage Maybe
seven times
you know and I already you know
I was already on the phone with
Seinfeld you know what do you think
and uh I go down to this thing bright
and early I stand online
there's about 30 Comics I know like
maybe four of them five of them at that
time that's how much of an open Micra I
was I didn't say a word
but I never forget that I saw a bunch of
guys
with NBC shirts and HBO shirts and
Zanies Comedy Club and you know like big
comedy clubs in New York I forget it was
a it was 30 years ago
and I remember how I got intimidated
how I got intimidated and I went down I
signed my name
I sat there I watched like the first 10
comics I was like number 82. you know
and I think you only had three minutes
right of course and I never figured at
one point I just walked down there
really the bus and I was so ashamed of
myself
I never said that story before I just
thought about it about a month ago how
ashamed that was of myself
I had to walk back to the bus station
and get on the bus and that was the
longest bus ride
in my life Jake let's back up
though for a second so you before the
before you saw like when you were on
your way down there before you saw the
line were you confident
yeah I was probably high from the night
before you know and I thought I was
going to go down there and spank them
all you know and yeah and you think just
seeing the other Comics like you the
fact that they had done other rooms like
like I said I only knew like five or six
of the other comics
you know I was at the time I was a
boulder comic
and I did the broker on Tuesday night so
I never went into the Comedy Works on
Tuesday
so I only did one-nighters when
Jimmy abated would call me or somebody
I'd go to South Denver some uh
taco place or something like that so I
didn't really know a lot of people
so nobody ever nobody ever said a word
to me about a guy
but I always remembered and I remembered
how shitty I felt
not that I was gonna win that I left
yeah
that was a horrible feeling for a Savage
like myself so
after that I looked at it a little
differently you know
and I think a lot of young Comics should
look at it that way
get on stage as much as you can
it was very frustrating to me when I
heard stories about guys like you
that were doing 30 35 sets a month
living in Boston
and you know immediately I'm a hustler
and here I am doing 16 sets in Denver
right that's to the max you know so you
I mean you always had a good work I'm
surprised
was that the only time you bailed on a
set
yeah probably
that wasn't a set though that was a
contest
okay
what's the difference
I don't know
you're doing a set in front of a bunch
of people right that are looking at you
from a subjective type of manner okay
and that's a weird thing for a comic
either a comic could do that or they
can't do that
I ended up doing well on the Seattle
competition in 95
but I I did better than what I
anticipated
and then I went to San Francisco and
98 and I quit after the third night that
was brutal
what was brutal about it everything came
out of your pocket
the gas the driving the hotels and then
you got there some night and the judges
were San Francisco comics
you know no
you know it was just a party and they
were just milking you
and uh Celia Cruz was playing at the
House of Blues on a Saturday night and I
had a main room spot
because I thought I would do well I
thought I'd get disqualified or
something and I was right I didn't want
to be there and I just drove back to LA
I caught Sally a Cruz and I caught my
midnight spot at the main
room oh yeah I I don't like
I don't like contests I've done two I
never do well what we
I don't want to talk about
we don't have to talk about comedy the
whole time I uh I'm happy you brought
this up with the bombing but we were
talking about something earlier
that because we're both fans of Cinema
oh yeah I think that real big connection
is Cinema I remember going to your house
one day and seeing all your CDs and all
your movies I mean half of them were
shitty movies
not some of them were terrible movies
uh you know
uh I love it
and I noticed that you were a movie buff
and you'd go to the movies
a lot and one of our similarities is we
really enjoy going to the movies alone I
got no beef with that oh I love it the
least people bother me that they're cold
thirsty their knees hurt
you know all that like it just and
now for the first time in my life I've
actually achieved
the goal of turning my phone off
you turn your phone all the way off when
I lived in L.A I always had it on right
and 20 minutes into the movie some
called you from an agency you get up to
call them there goes 10 minutes of the
movie and then you sit down and you
can't stop thinking about what they
called you about right
but we were talking about the
Stallone movie how it made who gots this
week and made two dollars because it was
a hundred million dollars to make or
something like that so if you make a if
you got a hundred million dollar movie
I'm just throwing a number out there and
it makes eight million dollars opening
weekend
I guess this weekend it was the worst
box office
in heaven
and you said something interesting
because you were right all up and down
the East Coast it was raining this
weekend was the perfect like it's like
everyone else all like everyone else who
like goes out and Hikes and they love
doing outdoor this weekend was like I
would have killed it
you and I discussed on yeah Friday and I
go I don't know what's out there and you
said the equalized I said I caught it
the first night right because moving
back here I have three theaters close
for me
and tickets go they always have two sets
of shows going on at one two on the
other so I always got an option you know
and I'm just trying to take it back to
see what
and I've been to the theaters I've had a
great time because all the movies I've
gone to see are basically empty
even though they're buses they've been
empty when I go there yeah and I
know that when I take my daughter it's a
50 show
for uh the popcorn what part of like the
AMC Network we get coupons and
discounts I mean they have different
lines they have eight different groups
you could sign up for now I I loved AMC
I worked at AMC for it was my favorite
job I got free movie tickets and they've
let me ask you why did you decide not to
go
this weekend mm-hmm
because there was nothing out there
even if I didn't want to watch the
expandable I've never watched an
Expendable movie in my life
not even close I love every type of
genre movie
but that didn't look appealing to me I
couldn't go for listen I've seen one of
the greatest combo movies of all time
The Dirty Dozen the Magnificent Seven
the original one not the one with what's
her name's half a husband
who's also on the Avengers and I
don't like none of that stuff Chris
Pratt yeah Chris Pratt I believe he's a
superhero
so but so that those were good but you
didn't what was it was it the age and
The Expendables why don't you buy The
Expendables
and I look like an expandable type of
guy like if you see me like all that
is going to be down
there with popcorn and a hot dog and his
shirt off for the I don't want his chest
you know yeah
because I know the Expendable people the
guys that have to be like Jet fans that
don't get tickets
they go it let's go see The
Expendables and instead of wearing a
green shirt they wear like no shirt with
a tattoo and they yell every time
Stallone's beating people up I can't
deal with that not right now Doug
anymore
oh yeah like what up anything else I was
telling Jimmy Florentine yesterday they
went to see uh Brett Michaels from
Poison
I can't do that no more I can't go see a
guy with mascara on he's 58 years old
knock it off and he's singing Sweet Home
Alabama which burns me up even more than
anything
get the out of here what what about
like what's wrong with Sweet Home
Alabama
it's a Lynyrd Skynyrd song why is there
a guy up there with mascara on this
thing in that song that's what
I'm getting at Lee
what about a kid
I got all of a sudden about three months
ago I discovered
this between us we're family of course
only do I have a fungi toenail not like
that
a Bursar in my ear
not only can I breathe you know the 60s
had Uncle Joey hard
I've been stealing father time for years
once I got 60 the warranty wanker put
you know that was it wake up puts I
don't have a Volkswagen I don't have the
Nazi 10 year 100 000 uh whatever
so
what was I talking about oh
he said I don't know you said you have
something new to tell like that's
happening to you all right so now I
discovered because I'm a clean ear
fanatic
no problem please go
yourself will you uh
I discovered what happened here hold on
go there you go there you go these
miserable
God damn it uh I discovered one morning
first of all this is one of my things
that bothered you ever talk to somebody
and you can see a piece of wax sticking
out of your ear you ever go to breakfast
somebody and they got accent whack I
don't give a if you got two uh food
in your teeth I don't give a if you
got the Sandman in your eyes I really
don't as long as you don't hit me with a
shot of bad breath and I don't see it on
ear wax I used to go to breakfast with
this dude
and he always had like ear wax sticking
out always this is 1998 when I first got
to La he was supposed to be a big night
manager but he never cleaned his
ears out and that always bothered me
about the guy that's why I didn't sign
with him because he he had dirty
ears and I like people got dirty
hands right so
now I'm 60 and a couple months
who I discovered
that I have wax in the mornings in my
ear when I scratch it sometimes I'm like
what the is this now I'm bad enough
with that I'm ashamed of that so I get
up in the morning now and as I'm peeing
I'm cleaning the earwax out of
my head right uh-huh
and then I discovered after about a
month of that not only did it have
excessive wax in my left ear only not my
right ear
that these Edibles are coming in because
I could see you like AI character
wax in my left ear
stinks like my belly button like
Houston you ever you ever smell a bad
belly button oh I I might smell my belly
button all the time
see that's a problem right there why
that's a problem and hold on one second
anyway what I was trying to get at is
that my earwax on the smells
smells so bad only on the left side
the right side and only that it's even
thicker like it's a like I gotta
clean it out with a Q-tip and then I
gotta get like a pen I got like
a certain pen I got from a funeral
parlor and it's got a certain Edge
pen
yeah listen nothing cleans your ears
better than a big pen the cap of the big
pen you can double you could do a
blasted Coke and then clean your ears
with the thing and the coke sticks to
the wax at least you got something in
the morning when you wake up and now for
a word from our sponsor
hey this episode is brought to you by
better help listen if anxiety has you
paralyzed like it had me it's really
hard to live the life you want therapy
is an amazing way to just break it down
your anxiety so you can live to the best
that you can guys better help is online
therapy that's an amazing tool and all
you do is take a quick quiz to get your
match with a licensed therapist and
you'll be on your way Tip Top Magoo you
can talk to your therapist on a video
chat by phone or even just message
however whatever you want to do therapy
is totally up to you listen when I moved
to Jersey I had some struggles with
anxiety boom I contacted better help and
here we are three years later I'm
jumping up and down like a Savage if you
don't get to jail with your first
therapist you can easily switch anytime
at no additional charge no questions
asked okay get up break from your
thoughts With Better Health
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p visit betterhelp.com
slash Diaz today d i a z to get 10 off
on your first month that's
betterhelp.com Diaz
did you ever talk to you about my ear
wax issues I don't feel I don't
shouldn't put them on Front Street but
it you know maybe somebody's uncle
has stinky is I don't know give me some
advice
you know they have a pen like a thing a
cleaner with a camera in it that you can
attach to your phone and you can like
see inside your ear and clean the wax
out so you don't have to like do it with
a big pen let's pretend I eat a mushroom
and I forget about it and also I got a
sudden whack each of my and I stick that
pen in there yeah you don't want to be
around let me tell you something those
mushrooms are starting to become
dangerous by the way
this weekend I had a rough
Sunday but it was a good Sunday
I got up did what I had to do around the
house with the family
and at one o'clock I got the Jimmy
florentine's part of the Florentine
crime family I got to this house a
little earlier to get a good seat
and I don't know somewhere along the
line I ate like six pieces of a
tremendous bar
I hate when that happens yeah and it got
a little something on the wing but then
ABX
the makers of the Tom Segura killers
uh in fact you could put this picture up
that I sent you the bag the maker of the
Tom segurus
okay they gave me like a little bag of
like uh
these organic mushrooms you know well
let's start from Saturday Saturday I had
taffies mushroom taffies and I I can't
see without my glasses right so I look
at the bag and I see 2 000 milligrams
okay so each piece of Daffy is 2 000
milligrams so I take a half and buy it
out of it I wait an hour when nothing's
happening I'm watching Colorado getting
beat up by Oregon State if you had
Colorado in the 30 it's still a loser
you know what I'm saying
the worst weekend of their life
I wouldn't want to be in Colorado for
that because there's got to be an
earthquake or something coming there
they got beat up in college and forget
about what happened that dude Sean
Payton should get fired today
oh my God I'm surprised he that's that's
a bomb of like I would put 70 to 20
that's crazy that's not good that's good
that's not good something's got to come
from this they got to put the hammer
down when the whip comes down it's time
you can't be losing 70 to 20
on week three of the NFL this can't be
happening now
on the other side of that I ate those
mushrooms at the first quarter those
things started backfiring I started
seeing things
so for a minute there I saw all those
touchdowns I'm like oh this is part of
the mushroom trip Miami ain't scoring
all those points and then I got up I had
to take a mushroom oh my God it
stunk so bad and I wanted like a
mushroom trash when I was in there and I
almost fell off the toilet it was
hilarious even Jim goes what happened in
the bathroom bruh the killer one I
brought a whistle
what I brought a whistle like uh like a
regular whistle that you give like you
know when people get hit on the head or
they see somebody getting robbed they
blow a whistle like that's gonna really
save you right
hmm I know what it was oh my God why do
you have a whistle oh yeah when you were
refereeing your car right so
I took the whistle with me and every
time they scored I would blow a
whistle and those people were going
crazy but my friend's son was there
great kid and every time I blew the
whistle he wasn't used to Uncle Joey he
would Elevate two inches from the
couch because I would just go
baby
it was like the Cubans at the Miami
Stadium they don't just show up with
water and cheese like these
Gentiles they show up with a chicken a
Conga drum some tambourines that's how
you win a game Jack
you must have been blowing that whistle
all goddamn day I blew the whistle all
dead I don't have to blow it it
just it comes with uh a thousand come on
dogs you have a a
motorized whistle yeah like one that you
just press you shouldn't be allowed to
have that you know it's I'm danger now I
stop at lights I see people I blow the
whistle and be gone they got a double
even
you know how they have those apps we're
like it's like cool like neighborhood
and people in your neighborhood can
write I guarantee someone like
someone's blowing a whistle in New
Jersey
you're blowing wisdom with that people
oh
you're what you're blowing with me what
you're blowing whistles at people now I
see people like waiting for the bus I
hit him with a whistle and a beep I hit
him with a double
they don't see the whistle they don't
think it's me because my hands out the
window hitting the buzzer
like it's a beautiful day to be alive
what's over here over there I bang them
with a whistle they pop up then I hit
him with a horn I keep going they don't
know nothing I saw a guy with a flat
today in the rain I hit him with a
couple whistle
guys
[Laughter]
I'm just trying to have a fun time I'm
an old man I ain't got time you don't
tell anybody and you don't you don't
I think you would do this whether or not
you were a comic like you would just I
think that's part of who you are it's
just torturing you love it
like that guy I bet you're gonna giggle
tonight as you're going to bed thinking
about the guy with the changing the tire
oh my God
he was having a bad day as it was he
didn't need something deep in the order
giving them a disco wisdom laughs
[Laughter]
comedy wherever it comes you know what
I'm saying sometimes comedy is right
in front of you it's so silly
how in front of you it is sometimes oh
but hey
let's talk about communism what they got
to offer you this week and I had a good
week how'd you do two out of three I did
well I picked uh
San Diego and then over Minnesota and I
I
um I had the Patriots and the under I
think but those I lost we lost the over
with Baltimore Indy it went under 44
which is crazy Saturday I took a beat in
the lead type beaten not a beating
because you know me I bet it light I
don't believe the hype like Colorado 50
boost
from DraftKings on college football and
then Sunday
I opened up with Miami
small because the line dropped from six
and a half to six
I also went with my team Detroit Lions
they always cover they're like a thief
in the night they always deliver the
goods but they lost right didn't they
lose they won they won they won okay
I had Cincinnati giving Pittsburgh a run
and a half on the Lord's day after they
dropped two you gotta go with them and
they came through like a fat cat
and there was something else and that oh
I took a beating with this one not a
beating again 25 bucks the Jets plus the
three and a half I thought New
England would beat them by three and I'd
win with the hook but not this week the
Jets are just that bad and now
for a word from DraftKings Jack
hey we're back here with another week of
football and DraftKings has us covered
for great offers every game again new
customers bet the small five dollars and
got 200 instantly in bonus bets for a
price of a cup of coffee that's right
you'll walk away with an instant winner
all customers can take advantage of two
new offers every single game this
September football's more fun when
you're in on the action stop sitting on
the sideline download the app now and
sign up with code Joey
j-o-e-y new customers again five dollars
to get you 200 in bonus bets and then
all you do is wait for profit boost this
that only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL with code Joey
j-o-e-y with DraftKings the crown is
yours
one problem do you have a gambling
problem we can't have that call 1-800
Gambler or visit
www.1800
gambler.net if you're a New York call
8778 Hope New York or text Hope New York
467-369 if you're in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly get
your act together
download the app use code Joey and let's
get in on the action it's time to have
some fun especially if you had Colorado
last week
I sent that dude that text I sent you
with the naked woman with the big tits
up and up and down what was she saying
in Israeli salons she was saying uh
Happy New Year who's better than me I
sent them to every Jewish American I
knew and everybody got back to me thank
you one guy even wrote me what you told
me
which was creepy which is what
he wrote on there that that was a good
distraction to his fasting oh yeah
because you don't eat you're not
supposed to eat today so what time
Sunday at sundown I think I'm almost
positive the night before till Sun up or
at least yes it's Sundown to sundown
I think
so they're eating right now
oh yeah
right now now they're throwing down like
Savages you've never seen so
much locks I used to go
to it there was a family that we were
friends with that was Italian but the
one of them converted to marry a Jewish
lady very very nice more food than I've
seen in my entire life
that haven't eaten for a whole day oh
do they no package they ain't
leaving nothing but silverware if not
have you had holla before how much what
the bread yeah not bad I mean I wouldn't
put a meatball on it but
people it's like Black Friday at the end
of the services they're very they're
polite but it's they're moving fast
because at the end of the last moment
you can eat they have challah and like
grape juice for kids or wine for adults
with apples and honey I I don't eat
that's the only time of the year I eat
apples I don't eat apples
that's your problem I know you gotta eat
more apples I've been dropping apples in
the morning and at night
Tip Top Magoo everything comes out nice
and smooth in the morning the only thing
is I can't do a bong has a at the
same time I had that superb back from
California where I just opened up the
back door sat down blew a bong hit and
that missile would come out of the
launch like a Boop nothing you
can't you can't cut a window into your
bathroom no
raccoon moves in forget about it I got a
lot of animals down there Lee a lot of
animals dog what do you think about them
what's your favorite
you know when I when I pet the raccoons
it's great when I feed them
I don't know
they're all my favorite you don't like
looking at them you know I don't know
maybe maybe like I don't know I
think deer are cool to look at sometimes
you see a wolf I I grew up around like
like wolves and like what is uh
coyotes I see a fox from time to time
there's a fox that lives by the Little
League field up the corner there
I swear to God I used to walk there and
I got attacked by a deer there one time
so I stopped walking up there and then I
realized why because it was a mom in a
little Cub whatever whatever
they called I'm not a hunter
because it was a baby deer and a big
deer I think it's a fun isn't it yeah
fun and that was coming at
me
and then I've seen a fox up there
because one day I decided to walk up
there to the back instead of Drive
that up never do that again
that's when I saw the fox I was like I'm
a dead man but I see a lot of a deer a
lot of beautiful looking deer
believe it or not there was two turkeys
on my corner the other day if I would
have had a bow and arrow everybody would
have had Thanksgiving on my block you
know what I'm saying but dude that taste
turkeys that come around like once a
month
those are scary like those I didn't know
deer attacked but like I've been like if
they're on the news here like there's
like this this year like an old lady got
attacked by a turkey like those things
are vicious
Doug the best was about three weeks ago
on route nine
somebody a truck
like a ton of potato chips fell off
there like oh I mean I saw them on the
thing like it must have happened 10
minutes before I got there it's not a
bit it's the nine but to the side it was
one of those side streets the left turn
and he dropped the point I went by there
the next day it was all raccoons not
raccoons I'm sorry squirrels eating them
oh dad the uh those pork
loins you know they were that's what
they were eating they were eating pork
rinds oh yeah pork rinds the low
sugar whatever the they are those
red ones from Wawa
I'm thinking about Wawa tonight and
I haven't eaten dinner yet oh what's
gonna be your order
my order at Wawa yeah what short sub
okay little one tuna American cheese
red wine vinegar oil extra snow
salt and pepper lettuce tomato onions
hot peppers
I'm surprised to go with I know you told
me this but I'm
tuna out is like scary like that's
too much and you like it it's scary
because you're eating some dolphin you
got meow meow soup in there you got some
eyeballs in there but this is Jersey you
said we're back back tuna it's not gonna
work out for you Wawa I mean I told Ari
the other day when Ari first came to my
house
he ran in here like a child with
10 bags
and I go I'm going out with he goes you
have a Wawa and I'm like what the
are you talking because I love Wawa the
sandwiches are great I'm like this guy's
I actually had to eat my words and call
him a week ago and go you were right I
love Wawa so much I downloaded this
app
you put your order in before you get
there yep
I would never have guessed you would do
that do you make your wife do it or do
you do it we both do it
that's awesome
how often you go to Wawa
once a week like at night once a week
for like a dinner like we get caught up
here with a softball game or
some activity I got no beef with going
to Wawa and getting a turkey sandwich if
you're not in the mood to eat they got
smoothies I have I'm gonna tell you one
thing
the person who turned me on to Wawa was
somebody I grew up with we went to the
beach
two summers ago and I said something
that I was hungry I was going to walk
and she goes no I stopped at Wawa and
got sandwiches and I grew up with this
girl you know she ain't gonna walk in
the Subway or nothing she's from the
same mindset she's my age
she goes try this uh Wawa
tuna sandwich
with hot peppers and sweet peppers I
almost died wait how good it was I was
in shock I really really was
so if I'm in a pinch look I'm not gonna
eat the pizza from Wawa when you have
what we have over here that's a waste of
energy
but I've heard from people that again I
trust I like these people that they've
gone in there to tell me how good the
burritos are in Wawa
and I had another brother of mine tell
me he loved the enchiladas but
he lives in Delaware so I gotta get my
pass
yeah they don't I was not like Steve
Simone turned me on to Wawa
and did
for a stoner
it's it's heaven it's just everything
that you can do and that you can do it
on the computer
and you have to tell you don't have to
talk to anybody
that's like the worst part of going out
when you're high sometimes
but
it kills me when it's sometimes the one
one of the ones by your house I don't
like there's like there's a there's bad
ones and I think I think they're hires
like it's always bad but I have a guess
um
smart
okay so I get a little bit higher level
where this one is it's a little higher
level to be honesty stores
spotless
you know uh I don't get anything I've
heard from the Grapevine
now I've had that in a pinch I had a
smoothie one day
and it was delicious
okay I didn't get the whipped cream or
nothing you know I'm trying to keep my
Bella figure
but I had the my neighbors and their
jerseys Staten Island people
they say they have tremendous milkshakes
yeah I love the milkshake the kids love
them the parents love them
see
I don't think you have the same rule I'm
I love a milkshake but I don't like
doing it during the meal so I never get
them out because I don't I don't want it
to melt I can't I have to do it in order
I don't know what it is like as fat as I
am and as many times as I went to
McDonald's
I never eat fries on the way home
there's rule like I can't you're a
chubby guy with rules I can't do it
but like me
this is why after this podcast
you're gonna call better help and get
some help
because you need help cocksucka you
don't yes I do one McDonald's
you eat everything you got as quick as
you can before you die
walk away with fries
because I don't know what you're talking
about it's gonna melt what what's gonna
melt you have to you eat it like
a gentleman you eat your burger and your
fries at home and then that's why I
can't get dessert it pisses me I can't
do it I can't have the milkshake before
the burger
first of all fruit let's get to the
bottom of this I know I gotta teach
fat man etiquette okay first off
in your kiss case because you're
addicted to that diet kosher which is
worse than smoking crack every night
if you got a cheeseburger if you got a
let's say a quarter pounder right with
cheese and a order of fries
right absolutely you're gonna drop a
uh
a Coke Zero in there with extra ice
whatever of course you might Dragon okay
but like for the regular consumer that
lives in Iowa yeah he's going to get one
of those stamenke shakes
and whatever like me I like my shake for
dessert like when I was throwing shakes
into the equation
I would go to a diner like I just
started going back to Edina and I'm very
happy I'm going back to my roots
my favorite one is a diner called the
Manila Pan Diner to have stolen my heart
the woman who's one of the owners is
from North Bergen originally she started
a diner on 6th Street in North Bergen
you know which I I know the diner I
can't remember the name of it right now
it's 8 15 at night but I uh
I uh go there once a week she's got a
fantastic split pea soup
uh
uh navy bean soup
I love my meatloaf
is to kill for and they just put
stew on the menu
because my wife ain't gonna make a stew
not well you know my daughter don't eat
that my wife makes a good stew but
it's gonna be we're gonna eat two
servings a piece I'd rather go over
there
spend a small 15 and get a nice bowl of
stew with six pieces of white
bread and butter and you just go off you
make sure you go to the gym that day you
do your jumping jacks you do your
kettlebells and you go there and it's a
treat for me
today does anyone else order stew what
brother does anyone else order still
yeah she does great with the stew there
it's winter time we've had rain for four
days I don't have to tell you that
down here I feel like people in The
Perfect Storm Marky Warburg and George
Clooney when they got killed up there
fishing with the other dude from
New Jack City
it has been raining a lot see you've
been loving that's I've been surprised
you I've been down to see you
10 times maybe all right somewhere we've
never been to a diner so you just
started going back I went back about
three months ago
before North Carolina I went back I
started with a cheese omelette with home
fries wheat toast
and a nice tea with extra lemon like a
doctor that's your test meal no sugar
yeah if you fail that we can't hang but
I've been in there a couple times before
that's what Vic d goes for breakfast
okay
goes there for breakfast and I've joined
them for breakfast day you know two eggs
sunny-side a bacon a bowl of oatmeal
who's better than you
they open up at seven
but I have a good breakfast at the house
so I don't go out to eat breakfast
anymore
I maintain a steady breakfast at the
house
half a piece of wheat toast two eggs
sunny-side up and a bowl of raspberries
bananas apples cantaloupes whatever I
can find
damn I'm trying to dog you gotta try
that's like a breakfast one of the
commercials that's like a real thing of
breakfast we finish up here with you
tonight okay eat like two more
of these Edibles all right nothing
tomorrow morning you know not that I'll
sleep till 10 you know but as
long as I know in my mind I got nothing
tomorrow morning maybe I'll stay up a
little late tonight watch something a
little later we got two games a Monday
Night Football Philadelphia Tampa Bay 7
15 I think 8 15. you got the Rams at
Cincinnati
you know what man
oh and the last time I checked yeah and
they don't give a they got two
games going on and that's good because
right now Jewish people could sit there
eat challah bread jump up and
down stew pastrami they could eat
anything they want tonight though right
no they can't I don't know if you can
eat let's do you probably have as kosher
beef you could
but like yeah but you could eat it's
usually breakfast it's good tonight oh I
love brisket with rye bread a little
Tomatoes you really are Jewish I
can't do the rye bread
come on now not like regular
stomacha bread there's rye bread and
then there's rye bread that
those people make at their own delis
yeah that's good nobody would ever
understand if I when I say to them go
eat pastrami at languages they'll look
at me and go why would I leave New York
to eat pastrami a language Joey let me
tell you something
the piece of bread you're gonna eat the
Pastrami and the language you're never
gonna eat a piece of bread like that in
your life
it's like a a rye Italian bread I can't
explain it to you
you know I cannot explain it to you
nobody would go there to eat pastrami
but I would I saw your boy Tom Hanks
there one time and sandwiches with a
bunch of foster kids I don't even know
if they were foster kids or he was
taking them to Bolivia on a family trip
well I see my boy
I don't know I thought you liked the
movie Big I do like the movie Big all
right then that is your boy
what do you got planned this week where
are the open mics at Lisa yet this
week's the big week man this week
Thursday through Saturday I'm in Omaha
at the Funny Bone opening for Josh Wolf
so I Primo number one Club the
owner there is uh
it's not an investor when you work
comedy clubs you're going to go to clubs
with the owners and investor he came
from a chain of restaurants and there
was a new mall opening and he figured
he'd buy a a funny bone or an improv or
something like that anybody could do
that
but
like it kills you that you go into these
clubs sometimes and this person that's
judging you
doesn't know anything about comedy
they've been doing comedy for they've
been watching comedy for three years
they
they bought into comedy you know like I
remember doing a club where the guy came
from a chain of restaurants
every time I go up to do 30 minutes he
would sit by the stage stand and just
look at me because he was petrified
and I had to pull him a cyber and then
go dog you got to knock it off
you know you make it well I just heard
of your behavior on stage and that's
what they came to see
they didn't come to see you stand there
on the side like a mummy
I'm telling you Lee he would stand
on the right side I'm sorry I thought it
was like on the right side there
right on the front page yeah right there
with his arms crossed like a
sleeping pill I can't have that no I
can't have that so we had words after
the first show Thursday we had words
again Friday and Saturday it was too
busy
you couldn't stand that it was too busy
I was a feature then
but I remember like he called me back
years later
you know to go I never stepped foot in
the club again but my point is
that when you do comedy and you're
getting beat up at every level
you know it's nice to work a club every
once in a while that the person has been
involved in comedy in some way or the
other for 30 years their whole life has
been comedy you know they were married
have kids and now this is their focus of
their life they take care of you like a
great comedy club owner they welcome you
when you get to your room there's always
something for you there in Nebraska
you know Colleen is uh
it's a four show five show weekend
you know it's a great club and
here's the crazy thing
when you're a young comic like from a
guy from Boston you take a Omaha
Nebraska and you're like well who am I
gonna talk to that a piece of beef what
am I gonna do that what's gonna come to
my show a butcher let me tell you
something people laugh harder than any
way you go
they take the ride with you they're
dirty
and there's nothing no better feeling
than that where
the comedy club owner only comes there
to watch you
to see and then give you confidence and
she's one of those club Owners so I'm so
excited that we're going there at this
level of your comedy career
because it's a breather
you know what man idiot that played the
piano in high school and now he wants to
tell you not to be say the word Jew on
stay and you're like
knock it the off take a hike around
the building will you
you know I'm a comedy podcast fan you
know we did the church for all that time
I love I listen to all of them
and there's a few clubs that like all of
you guys talk about
you talk about the store you talked
about like Cap City Comedy Works in
Denver
um zany so like there's a few clubs that
seem to be like clubs that like Comics
get excited about
and for some reason it just sticks in
your head because you're right it's
Omaha Nebraska which I don't think I
think I drove through once like everyone
talks about how cool it is
and
I'm just
yeah I'm just so excited
you know when as a comic you get so
excited about big moves
you know like this week I'm gonna go to
Vegas I remember the first time I went
to Vegas I'm not going to tell you the
club or the it was a week-long club and
it was one of the biggest
disappointments of my life
I can't tell you how sad I was by
Thursday
and I still had
you know eight more shows left
or something
all you want to do is go home you sign
up to do comedy next thing I'm on an
elevator getting hit by swords with
little kids you know
it was then I got the two shows a night
they come up to you before the show and
tell you got to be spotless I gotta wait
for the guy to walk out of the room for
me to do a joke or for a
joke or and I was like this ain't worth
it this isn't Las Vegas to me I thought
I was going to walk out of here like
Dean Martin and have a great
time but I also worked there with dice
in the beginning
and I saw how it was for a guy like in
his stature when we opened for him I go
up there and like my ball sacking on
fire nobody would say two words
to me you know what I'm saying but
anyway where you at this week brother
man I'm I'm in Omaha a ton of the rest
of the week I'll be at open mic and in
Worcester people came out to that the
com other comments of the the open mics
were very excited to hear about it so
I'm that's that's that and then I have
uh something October 5th in Connecticut
okay well let's not worry about the
fifth the next week we're about this
weekend see how you're gonna tackle it
I mean we're gonna want notes from here
okay on what Monday's podcast how you
think you did what could have been
better
I mean because this is a two-man show
right this is uh something that you only
did with me years ago where you got to
go up there and do 20 minutes and I used
to break your balls and go you gotta do
40 minutes tonight very nonchalantly you
know uh lee you earned your stripes
brother I used these don't
know how I used to give you Edibles and
tell you all day you were doing 10
minutes you would hate other comics and
then we get to the ice house and I go
everybody canceled
you've got 60 minutes and guys
it
you could just see the color lead with
little Jewish cheeks
and see steam coming out of his
ears and I would hold them to it for
about 20 minutes nobody else is coming
going back and get your material ready
he'd be making foolish noises you know
the whole thing and then he go
up there and do great you know 10
minutes 12 minutes and then I get off
stage and I will let him go I can't
believe you did that to me
I want to get my car and go home
that's the mark of a true comic
brother
and that's what I'm getting listen if we
call each other this is the same
conversation you hear people yeah
there's nothing edited here except you
know I tell them about DraftKings and
what I bet but besides that you know
this is what but you do tell me that
stuff
what's up you call we'll talk about
sports all the time oh yeah but we talk
about a lot of other things than that
yeah but it was one time is really good
on the phone and go deep with our topics
like when we talk about gay people and
Eric the and all that you know
how he jerks off on people's feet and
stuff you know that's that's the phone
call they want to hear but we're both
higher than and we're just dying on
the phone you know before I said to you
he called me up and he goes I already
took the Edibles I go I don't know you
don't sound and we start dying
of laughter that's what the check-in is
all about
what do you think absolutely
I love it man I love you tomorrow night
tomorrow night is uh I will be in two
places I'll be at the Blackstone in
Worcester
and I'll be at the at uh Rex animal
attacking
you're beautiful brother if you
go
to see any of these shows please say
hello to them
how he did
you know my Twitter's at Matt flavor let
me know if this should call
an Obama alert or uh no I have all the
confidence in the world you're gonna do
great this week brother that's a great
place she makes you feel at home so it
takes the steam off you know
again you're half neurotic but it could
be worse I could be that torture again
I'm way more than half neurotic but
thank you my brother have a great week
and let's uh close out the show it's
responses guys love you thank you for
checking out the checking checking out
the checking one of my idiots
stay black and I'll see you in October
bye guys
[Music]
blue Jew listen I love blue chew
everybody loves a guy who's self-assured
in the bedroom and Bluetooth can help
make sure you're ready whenever the mood
strikes blue chew is an online service
that delivers Ed medicine straight to
your door nobody knows nothing with the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra but at a fraction of the
cost just sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you're you receive your
prescription within days
it's all online no doctor's office
nobody giving you a brow beating it's a
beautiful thing they each come in a
little blue package when you feel
something or you bump into somebody that
could be a stranger you're pop one and
you do what you need to do Bluetooth
comes in a discreet package so your nosy
no neighbors don't ever know what they
got unless they want the Yum Yum you
know what I'm saying
Bluetooth wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com
again chew it and do it Jack that's a
special deal for our listeners try
Bluetooth free when you have promo code
Joey at checkout just pay five dollars
for shipping again that's
bluetooth.com code Joey T receive your
first month visit bluetooth.com for more
details remember promo code Joey and the
check-in is also brought to you by Babel
listen I know I'm babbling right now
anyway only 22 percent of Americans
speak a language can you believe that
even me Uncle Joey I got like three
languages
if you want to shake up your daily
routine why not learn a new language and
help raise that rate you ever get on a
on an Uber you don't know what nobody's
saying this is the perfect time when you
get a little boy to have Bible instead
of paying hundreds of dollars for a
private theater or use another language
apps the little more than games Babel is
an effective way to give your Uber
driver a tremendous air beat designed by
over 150 language experts using Babel
for just 15 hours 15 hours has shown to
be equivalent to a full semester of
college language course listen I played
with Babel a little bit I like that
little Spanish course give it a try you
know Spanish is the number one language
people are talking right now you want to
jump on that bandwagon you always want
to be able to get into the baseball game
you know what I'm saying with over 10
million subscriptions so Babel is a real
language learning for real conversations
here's a special limit
deal for our listeners to get you
started right now get 55 off your Babel
prescriptions but only
for our listeners at babel.com Joey
again
babble.com Joey I'm getting you 55 off
who gives you a deal like that nobody
spell Babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Joey rules and
restrictions May apply welcome to the
check-in